when we begin this newshour with
breaking news from afghanistan at least
five people have been killed in an
explosion in the capital kabul the
bombing targeted the entrance to a
mosque let's get more from al jazeera's
osama bin javid he joins us live from
kabul osama what more do you know about
this attack at this stage
this was the first time that a taliban
gathering of supporters and leaders has
been targeted in the capital kabul this
was a condolence meeting where people
were coming in uh to uh condole with the
spokesman for the talibans
who's the deputy minister of information
and culture as well whose mother passed
away a couple of days ago and there were
hundreds of people at this gathering uh
just a few minutes before the blast some
al jazeera team members were also there
and they described to us that there were
multiple rings of security around this
site where not just the badly brigade
but other taliban the other taliban
forces were trying to stop people search
them and they were only letting them
letting people go inside towards the
area where people were meeting the
spokesman after a thorough search
but because there were so many people
there there were hundreds of people
exiting the venue from the location as
well it is not clear exactly where this
blast took place
but we are fearing that there has been
multiple casualties we've heard from
taliban sources that at least five
people have been killed and others have
put the number a lot higher but this is
significant because taliban had been
speaking about security
safety in this country unprecedented
peace and it appears that those attacks
which have been happening on the
outskirts in jalalabad in other areas
have not come to the capital kabul i
will just talk us through some more of
the significance of this attack because
as you mentioned it's the first attack
in kabul
since the taliban came to power and a
lot of the taliban's big cell to the
population is that we're the ones who
can keep you safe
so
what does this attack
do
in the minds of people who are
in the country who are
looking and hoping for security
well what the taliban have been telling
the people of afghanistan is that now
they're in power there is unprecedented
peace there is no corruption and they
are going to build upon that everything
else that the rest of the world has been
asking them to do and now this attack in
the heart of the capital at a very
secure location tells the world that
there are certain threats that the
taliban have not been able to overcome
zabira mujahid has been a very a vocal
advocate a spokesman for the taliban
he'd been in the shadows only came to
light after the taliban took over and
just minutes before he left for this
venue we were with him and we were
asking him about uh what is the
situation like why are we seeing such a
high number of attacks in jalalabad in
the nangarhar province on the outskirts
of kabul
you have to remember that in the last
week or so there have been multiple
raids at homes where taliban have said
that these were isolated isil fighters
these were iceland afghanistan
supporters they were members of hidden
cells and zabirullah mujahid was very
adamant that isil is does not hold any
territory but it does pose a threat here
is some of what he told us just minutes
before he left for that when you were
the uh plastic place
isil is not a visible thing here they
are in hiding some disturbances have
been seen in kabul and jalalabad but
they are not present in other places we
are paying close attention and we will
not let them create unrest and our
suggestion to them is that they don't
instigate fighting inside afghanistan
this is an islamic country there is an
islamic government here foreign forces
have withdrawn from the country there
has been a major jihad done against
foreign occupation so everyone must
respect this and if they don't respect
this they will face a very powerful
reaction from afghan citizens and also
our forces we will filter them out and
will destroy their hideouts
we have to make it very clear that there
has been no claim of responsibility of
the attack here in kabul but this is a
group isil in harastan islamic state of
the iraq and iraq and levant in horison
province which is the wider afghanistan
central asian region which has been
carrying out these attacks in jalalabad
and nangarhar taliban have been
insisting that they are going after them
and they say they are going to be true
to the pledge to the rest of the world
that afghan soil is not going to be used
by any group against any other country
let alone afghan people so it is hugely
significant that this attack in the
heart of the capital kabul at a
gathering which was secured by taliban
fighters has taken place and now taliban
are going to have to tell
not just the afghan people but their
supporters as well about the
significance of the threat they face and
what are they going to do about it okay
osama bin javid that bring us up to date
from the afghan capital
osama thank you very much indeed
well let's get more on this now from
fahad nabil he joins us from islamabad
who's the security analyst and
researcher on militancy it's good to
speak to you i'm just going to repeat
what our correspondence said there has
been
no claim of responsibility for this
attack but given the context
of the situation that we're in now
which groups would you say would be
among the the first that you would
suspect
who i mean who
do you think would be attacking it looks
like the taliban themselves are being
attacked
well one cannot rule out the possibility
that islamic state horizon province
might possibly be behind this attack
however so far they have not officially
claimed this attack but there's a strong
likelihood that they might be behind
this attack and in terms of the
significance of this uh this is the
first time the taliban have been
attacked it is the first time since the
afghan capital was attacked since the
taliban takeover
what do you think this speaks in terms
of the threat level for
for civilians in afghanistan because
again the the taliban are meant to be
ensuring security and with bomb attacks
and mosque attacks it looks like i mean
this will have many people uh on edge
really it almost seems like the war
isn't over
ever since the taliban takeover we have
seen a surge of activity by islamic
state for some province however this is
the first high profile attack since the
kabul airport track by slang straight
for some prevents so these attacks the
continue frequency of these attacks is
really putting a serious question on the
capabilities of afghan talent to protect
not only
kabul which is the capital but all
across afghanistan as well and so what
how would you assess the taliban's
ability to to protect civilians and to
protect themselves from the type of
attacks which when they were at war as
part of the civil war they were carrying
out does this give them an advantage if
they're using the same
uh
their adversaries now or using the same
tactics that arguably they use
uh yes definitely of one taliban now if
it's the same threat which they used to
pose to the foreign security forces or
the foreign troops in afghanistan so it
is important for them to realize this
fact that they have to move from this
insurgency mode to now governance world
where they have to ensure they have to
isolate locate the slipper cells of
islamic state for sanctuaries there have
been an operation a few days ago in
kabul so they have to continue to locate
isolate the the elements of slangster
horizon province in order to deal with
this threat and do you think they will
be able to deal with that they obviously
have a country to run which th they're
learning how to do very quickly they've
been thrown in the deep end if you like
when it comes to
running the country do they have the
resource the ability to to undertake the
second mammoth task when it comes to
tackling insurgent groups like this
it is a very difficult task for one type
and because it does not have this uh
experience they did
were in the governor's mode back in the
late 90s however this time around the
challenges are different they have this
threat of islamic state horizon province
which uses the same tactics which have
one television have been using the past
so it is very important and they have
this capacity building issues as well
but they do also face this dilemma of
foreign military groups in afghanistan
which the neighboring countries and
other extra regional countries have been
arguing them to take action against them
so they also face this dilemma if they
to go and take action against those
foreign uh militant groups and
afghanistan they have this possibility
of those groups joining islamic state
horizon province and and and just how
how powerful are ice okay again we we're
not we still don't know who carried out
this attack but as a group
i mean are they more powerful than than
perhaps people have thought them to be
is there a chance that not just the
taliban but other world powers are
underestimating how strong this group is
uh as last year for some problems uh for
a few years back they were downgraded a
lot by the efforts of uh foreign
security forces the foreign security
forces
inaudible itself but over the past years
or so it has rese has witnessed we have
witnessed a resurgence of their
activities
so it continuously poses a threat and it
uh one can say that the as the threat of
slangster horizon province has been
largely underestimated okay
we're out of time but great to get your
thoughts thank you so much for joining
us from islamabad
thank you